Hello. So, Eric here. Today we came to
Co or is that the
Ou within the
Smurb for us to come and survey a new
field that one of our clients want to
put to uh use. After surveying it, we
will be able to choose the particular
crop. But key among them was to know the
history of the land what they've used it
for over a period of time where we are
going to source water of course to also
make sure the land belongs to them and
thankfully they came to meet uh their
neighbors in order to make sure
everything align with each other and
also one of their threat even before we
start is cattle invasion. They usually
see a lot of cattle. The land has been
used from 2012 and then they went on a
pause cultivating some crop like
tomatoes, okra and what have you. And
you also do cava the farm owners are
here and then we have key trees like
palm tree one of them some few coconuts
about eight acres. So from here you
can't see all of them but just to give
you a very close shot and a good view
the land is good. We have some part that
is a little slopy and then some part
that is very flat when you go uphill.
The intention of course is to construct
a mini dam that will serve during the
dry season if possible. During the rainy
season we accumulate water and then
during the dry season will be
sustainable and surely we are able to uh
supply or prod produce throughout the
entire season. This is what we do. We
start with you from the word go. We come
to see the realities on ground. Then we
are able to prepare a well customized
budget for your case. And we always say
we we will not touch your money. We will
let you spend the money as we go. We are
just a guide who are guiding you through
where to pick items that you are needed
the quality basic quality standards in
order to make your investment a good
deal for you. Thank you and see you
[Music]
again. Hey, hey, hey.